let's uh let's get let's get partisan
here because oh boy this poll here is
i'm gonna gloat no boy from axios young
democrats more likely to despise the
other party
and so when people say like you know why
does tim talk about the democrats so
much this
exemplifies everything mitch mcconnell
recently came out he was talking about
the midterms the way the that new york
mag put it is that mitch mcconnell is
running on pure obstruction for 2022.
not that i trust their opinions on this
but that's on par for what the
republican establishment does nothing
they obstruct i've been saying that
since what 2017 i've been like what am i
going to complain about republicans for
yeah they sit around doing nothing
democrats are enacting policy that is
detrimental to this country they're
they're failing to secure the border
right now with biden power they're
trying to ban guns and republicans do
nothing
now you see this
college this is this is a poll we have
from axios
generation lab axios polling college
students who would not and then poll
question someone who voted for the
opposing presidential candidate so
basically
71 of young democrats would not date a
republican 41 would not support a
business of a republican 37 percent
won't even be friends with a republican
30 won't work for one among republicans
31 percent won't date a democrat seven
percent won't support a democrat
business five percent won't be friends
with democrats and only seven percent
won't work for democrats this is a
problem
now look
i don't like division i don't like
people fighting but if republicans are
willing to support the businesses of
those who hate them they will lose be
friends with everybody work for well
actually and don't work for these
companies go on a date with anybody help
change people's minds
uh i think we're conflating who owns the
businesses here not the college students
so the college students are the ones who
are deciding that they won't work for a
company or patronize a business that
doesn't have their political views but
the people that own those businesses are
slightly different than the college
students so i understand what you're
saying but like this is a great example
of the politics of hate the politics of
division that are being implemented on
college campuses and bleeded and drummed
into your children on a daily basis to
hate to hate to hate to give no quarter
to there's no reason to be compromising
with any of these people there's no
reason they're saying there's no reason
to have any empathy sympathy no
understanding no reaching out across the
aisle if it feels like they hate you
more than we hate them it's 100 true by
by multiple factors this cannot survive
and so this makes me optimistic
a movement built upon hating the other
will not work and the democrats know it
which is likely why so many have retired
because they're sitting there saying
what am i going to campaign on none of
these people care these younger
democrats care about any of these issues
they just hate republicans well i can't
win over moderates who lean republican
if i'm campaigning on why they're
awful how much power does this
constituency have
is it enough to drive a political
candidate's decision-making to say that
college students won't do this that or
the other that they have these
predispositions it's not about college
students i mean college students can
range from what 18 to 24 on average you
know maybe a little bit of at least the
least vote list mr efforts of them all
it's like it's like i was telling you
before the show i mentioned this that
the person running against lauren bobert
texts me because i had donated to some i
donated more democrats than i've ever
done i've done it to like four democrats
like two republicans in my tongue
and so i end up getting all these
messages from democrats and they were
like help support me with my fundraiser
i'm running against lauren bobert we
have to stop her and the maga blah blah
blah and i'm like what are you
campaigning for
why are you running for office do you
want to fix the roads do you want to get
universal healthcare or something no you
just hate lauren beaubert
stop texting me she's following the same
lead that uh all of the democrats
followed when it became to just hate
donald trump hate donald trump donald
trump trump did that too like he made
fun of hillary made fun of him and then
and the republican the republican
candidates following in his wake do the
same things they utilize the same
tactics so it's natural for people to
glom onto and to adopt winning practices
of people that come before them which is
why i'm pretty optimistic actually on
the future of the feminized society and
the feminist movement is is is the
opposite is that you've got a whole
generation looking ahead all these women
who are failed right who are in their
late 30s who have their careers but have
no families and are upset and
disappointed maybe there's youth who are
looking ahead at that signal and are
saying hey i'm not going to live that
life so it's the same mechanism the same
channel right trump did this he called
people names he belittled people in some
ways you know with the fake names and
all that and then that that spawned an
entire generation of people mimicking
him towards his success joe biden got
elected without any real positions
without even campaigning because it was
just like we hate donald trump and so of
course now there's gonna be a bunch of
politicians in his wake doing that so
this is like a monkey see monkey do kind
of thing and uh you know it's not
unexpected but i don't think that it has
absolutely any legs whatsoever and i
think one of the interesting parts about
it was that like what was it 70 percent
70 percent of college democrats won't
even date a republican only six
how many were pulled like what was this
poll
every single one every college student
every single one
all across time and it was perfect yeah
forever yeah
i wonder how many colleges were pulled
how many students if there's like a
thousand students if this is a hundred
thousand students because it's also it's
also just a display democrats in college
of power and of survivability right if
you're a democrat or a republican on
campus most of the time you're going to
be a minority so it's like am i going to
eat am i going to date am i going to be
able to go to subway well then yes i'm
going to support a business that's owned
by somebody who disagrees with me
politically whereas in the comfort of
their college environment the democrat
kids are very capable and able being
like no i'm only going to patronize
people that see the world my way they
haven't made it out into the real world
where there's other people out there and
other viewpoints and other things and
they haven't had a chance to like be
hungry if they're going to adhere to
that uh that that sort of principle yeah
this is an interesting uh peer into the
mind of a college student tim do you
have numbers on
uh this poll how many people or where
no we can try and pull it up though yeah
but i'm trying to dig through that right
now it's funny that they don't put that
info at the top they really should
the
data here we go there's a lot there's a
lot more stuff how uh given the effects
of kobe 19 how important is it for you
to live in the town city where your job
is
you know and then axios polls what they
think is important you know people based
on their income let's see here we go
here we go would you go out on a date
with someone that voted for the opposing
presidential candidate
probably 32 probably not 32 18
definitely definitely and then i guess
when you get into the actual oh look at
that income levels
people who make more than 130 000 or 20
unlikely they say they wouldn't uh date
someone but poor people are the most
likely to not to definitely not date
someone
and then what do we have probably not
definitely not political id and then
here you go here's this data what is
this wait seven percent definitely would
you on a date with someone that voted
for the opposing presidential candidate
oh okay
seven percent said uh definitely meaning
they they would right and definitely not
is 30 and probably not as 41 so i think
that's the that's where they're getting
the 71 percent from
so there you go that's actually
important to break down too because
probably not is not no not the same the
way axios framed it so breaking down the
data is is is is important what's axios
is lean
they're left they're like center center
left yeah yeah they're pretty good
71
what does it say would not someone who
voted for the opposing personal
candidate so that's actually uh
misleading fairly misleading absolutely
oh what do you know
probably not and so they've missed
they've misled us on their own data in
order to make a point that they stand
behind and believe is important to push
out to the universe which is hate hate
hate hate everybody hates we all hate
you wanna hate with us but but to be
fair we break it down it is still
leaning in democrats so look republicans
are still only probably not 24 and
definitely not seven percent meaning
republicans are still more tolerant of
the opposing political views than
democrats are
so that's that's an important takeaway
from here and my view of it is just
basically when people are like why why
tim do you claim to be lefty but hate
the democrats that it's like what are
the democrats have to do with the left
and then when the when the leftists like
the you know hassan and and people like
him and vosh are like tim's far right
i'm like the only thing we disagree on
is reality like i can tell you
definitively like when we had vosh here
oh no you know hunter avalon was here
yeah and he actually i would have let
this go because i'm you know sometimes
i'll let people you know
i'll let people have their opinions but
when we were talking about
it's true when we were talking about
bharisma yeah and victor shulkin and
luchevsky and stuff he actually told me
i was wrong and then pushed back on me
and then i was like do you have any idea
what you're talking about and then i
went off i'm like bro i did so much
research on the hunter biden barisma
stuff and then followed up matt taibi's
reporting i started reading through what
he was reporting on i have dug through
that and i talked to these people they
don't know they don't believe it and
that's the problem you can be on the
left you can believe in whatever
economic policies you want but if you
don't know what reality is because you
don't do research then i'm sorry we
disagree on fundamental reality and a
really good example of this is david
pakman david pakman and i probably agree
on a whole lot of things because i've
known the guy for a really long time the
problem is david pakman isn't a
journalist i'm not saying that
disparagingly he just doesn't do
research he literally doesn't he had a
segment where he was mocking ted cruz
for saying that ukraine meddled in the
2016 election to help the clintons which
was reported by politico and the new
york times reported that ukrainian court
even said as such that isn't to say that
ukraine as a government was secretly
trying to overthrow the us or anything
like that but that special interests in
ukraine were doing this david pakman
puts out a video where he mocks ted cruz
for being correct and i'm like bro if
you didn't even bother to google this we
have a fundamental problem we can agree
on policy positions we probably agree on
a lot but don't call me right wing
because i believe in the truth and you
didn't google it
at the state of politics i think that's
a pretty good um indicator is like are
you willing to do the work if you do the
work
and you really do the research and you
read and you're open-minded to things
that may not resonate immediately with
you it's a sign it must correlate with
being right-wing in this new environment
that's it right instead of just taking
things that make you feel good or
actually in this case make you feel bad
right these people are reacting to being
told things that make them feel bad and
then they stop there there was there was
a story there's a there's a car accident
and one of the guys in the accident is
walking to his car where has his gun on
his dashboard it's a it's a young black
man
and the cop who's also black says just
leave your stuff there just leave your
stuff there man and the guy said
something like i gotta grab my stuff and
then he grabs her the gun and the cop
shoots him fires twice one bullet hits
the k hits the guy in the leg is 20
years old and the cops like why did you
reach for the gun man why did you reach
for the gun and so i tweeted
if you are not a suspect in a crime and
you want to pick up your gun a cop
should not be able to use lethal force
against you it's a constitutional right
to keep and bear arms and what did the
lefties on twitter say
they said how come tim doesn't defend
black people when they're attacked by
police oh surprise surprise this story
he's defending them i'm like
they don't care they don't care about
what's true they didn't bother to read
the story they just want to believe some
preconceived zombie npc narrative and
i'm like yo
we agree
i think it was wrong the cop shot the
young black man because he was trying to
pick up his gun he's allowed to have a
gun and the right said that that was a
good shoot because he was wanted on drug
and gun charges and i'm like non-violent
crime he was legally allowed to own a
weapon and you think he should like he
can't have weapon because he's one i'm
sorry dude and they were like he was
wanted by the atf and i'm like yo when i
tweet abolish the atf you guys retweet
it now you're gonna sit here and see a
guy who's in a car accident was trying
to pick up his gun it should get shot
because you shouldn't have done that
sorry dude you have a right to keep and
bear arms a cop shouldn't be like oh no
a guy's keeping him bearing arms then
shooting you but the left instead of
agreeing with me argues with me a really
great example is hassan talking about
the ahmed arbory case and we're tweeting
at each other and i'm just like it's
really weird that you and i agree on
this but you're turning it into an
argument
this poll i think exemplifies a lot of
what that is
pure hatred
that's it i'm old enough to remember
when tim poole wasn't a donald trump
supporter
right
and i've never i've never i've never
been a gung-ho zealot for the man no
definitely not and even to this day
we've mentioned now i think like a
couple dozen times that he's been
implicating the lolita express because i
don't care if if it's trump if it's
clinton i don't care who it is if
they're flying on that plane give me the
evidence and we'll talk about it the
problem we have today is the modern left
the democratic establishment and all the
people who vote for biden have no idea
what's really happening in the world and
it's thanks to the likes of cnn and
msnbc and these other fake news outlets
who are imploding they're imploding cnn
and msnbc are imploding is that not a
sign is that a signal
that the like something positive is
happening if cnn and msnbc are imploding
and that and that
that genre of pedaling of that
information may not be actually working
out but youtube still puts them on the
front page
and they got rid of the dislike button
because all of the news segments were
disliked to oblivion a lot of people say
that youtube got rid of the dislike
counter because of joe biden i think
it's because of mainstream media
i think it's because when you go on the
front page you see cnn abc nbc thumbs
down 80 on every video because people
are like they're lying dude
so
do those videos from the mainstream do
they get more views to generate more
youtube revenue oh yeah cnn got 100
million views last month okay that's
five times what we got on this show okay
so so it's financially motivated
and i can respect that well look if
youtube got rid of cnn if youtube
promoted real news and real commentary
and authenticity they'd probably make
more money but they don't care youtube's
subsidized by alphabet anyway so what do
they care they want to prop up the
narrative from the establishment media
safer for advertisers i guess that's
what they're thinking or it's just they
want the narrative to persist yeah so
they give freebies to cnn and cnn is
getting the views it's it's true because
regular people go on youtube and they
see it they click it
that's it and that's reality for them
now and it's it's really frustrating man
especially with the holidays because i
tell you what it's like you know i'm
gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna go spend time
with some people on christmas and i'm i
am assured there's gonna be a bunch of
people who have no idea what they're
talking about but are arrogant as all
hell
and that'll be interesting but i don't
know i don't know i don't i don't you
know i don't want to prejudge people and
my attitude is like look if someone says
something incorrect to me i'm not going
to yell at him or argue with them if
someone says like biden didn't have a
quid pro quo with you know uh with the
uh in in ukraine with uh zlatchevsky or
um i'm sorry i was not zlatchevsky
that's the um personal guy with the
president of ukraine i'm forgetting his
name off to make sure i double check
that stuff i'll just be like very simply
like
there were 12 open investigations that
victor shokan had into burisma michael
sladchevsky fled the country when he was
under investigation as his bank account
frozen as soon as as soon as joe biden
does that quid pro quo saying i want a
billion dollars what happens is the dude
comes back this isn't the holidays
you're talking about you're planning
your return
to
people disputing the facts that you know
to be true i am not at all i'm not doing
that at all i'm making a point about how
i will respond in these scenarios that
people often like to talk about where
people get in political arguments i
would suggest that perhaps at christmas
it might be best just to respond with
like oh wow
and then move on to something i disagree
jack i think we need to i think we need
honesty we need real conversations we
need to level with people and i i think
a little bit of argument a little bit of
fighting is okay it's good and we
shouldn't shy away from it and act fake
and pretentious and like somebody that
we're not faking pretentious well i say
that's usually where it starts it starts
off with just placating people and
saying oh haha yes okay yeah and then
not really truly expressing yourself and
then
later down the line that's going to
create a conflict where obviously you're
going to clash
but this is a problem we have stopped
talking about politics yeah i i agree
but what this is like is like a
heavyweight fighter going into an
amateur's house much like it would be if
you and i had a boxing match i don't
know about that
i want to make sure this is clear okay
there is the trope about during the
holidays people bring up politics
because of cnn my complaint is that the
media has lied to people and now i can
assume should these tropes prove true
people are going to say a bunch of
really dumb things and i'm not going to
argue with them i'm simply just going to
be like oh yeah with barisma it was you
know victor shoken was the prosecutor
right you knew that and and and
zlatchevsky who founded barisma was
wanted on a bunch of corruption charges
fled the country the eu throws his stuff
joe biden comes in all of a sudden the
charges get dismissed by the new
prosecutor biden got a new prosecutor in
and then the charges get dropped you
have to say that exact that exact way
that exact tone right
and i'm serious and you got to stand up
before you say it and i'll slam the
table no but i'll just be like i'll be
like look i don't know i'm not gonna you
know argue about it but no being a
journalist a new prosecutor being a
journalist and going to christmas
is like bringing a knife to a fight
where the other kid's bringing a stick
it's just it's just like you know it's
kind of stick
you can make you could kill somebody
with a scene i had a special forces guy
teach me how you could just take someone
out with the stick it is a good point
jack how you're saying it when you
discuss politics with your friends and
family that you don't talk about what
other people what you heard from other
people it's more important that you you
you are fully fleshed out with what you
know and what you've researched if
you're going to talk about it at all
because a lot of people are going to be
referencing cnn and just repeating it so
don't be the guy that references the
stuff on the other side to try and
counter that it's not going to work i
would even go on the opposite spectrum
and say it's your duty to inform people
when they're misinformed when they're
being allied to when they're being led
down a path that's going to end them up
hurt by the establishment i agree with
that
in a way that it's digestible
processable and doesn't alienate you
from the situation because the
relationship in this case is more
important so that you can give that slow
inoculation over time those that vaccine
and the booster and the booster and the
boost finally where they have the
immunity don't be special about you
don't you you don't ever raise your
voice
and you make sure you're always talking
facts because the problem is when you're
like an economy that's distributing this
percentage of stupid it's like well
you're in opinion territory if someone
says i think the society would be better
if we taxed the rich at 80 and i'd be
like well there's a thought you know
what i mean like i don't know like how
do you quantify whether it be better or
worse it's just an opinion you're
allowed to have one
facts are the issue thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 p.m and don't forget
to smash that like button subscribe to
this channel and if you want more
unfiltered and uncensored content with
all of these guests go to timcast.com
and become a member all of these guests
you know and love in exclusive segments
on our website where we are unrestricted
in what we talk about so you'll
definitely not want to miss it thanks
for hanging out we'll see you all next
time